it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes what up everybody you are watching
hash tag movie fights live welcome to
the party
and I gotta say hello to all of my
friends and hash tag owl Nation
hoo hoo Perceval in the house we got I
hope you like your movie fights with a
twist because we're gonna get Shyamalan
today it's all em night all the time at
least for the next hour or so let's meet
our combatants first oh he has quickly
won the hearts of America or at least
the people that watch movie fights he is
a former moon fights champion winner of
franchise fights our good friend
cucumber plus this time I got ya thank
you
Oh cucumber uh great to have you back
thank you for stepping back into the
squared circle here at movie fights
next up oh she is one of the hosts of FX
movie download just a great friend of
the family just she is a movie mind a
mother as so many splendid things Sasha
Pearl raver she is a huge fan of
cucumber and honestly yes I love this
little love fest and adding to the love
fest he's got the best hair on the
Internet at least or at least at screen
junkies welcome back to the party mr.
Joestar thank you
thank you for coming across the hall
writing probably a top-secret honest
trailer something that we don't we can't
know until it drops and yeah for Sasha
if it gets weird between cucumber and I
and you know what I mean when I say
weird just just let happen yeah I mean
it I I've agreed if I if it gets weird
between any of you guys in cucumber I'll
just sit back and watch we're all
friends here on that note let's say hi
to the Dan cam Dan Burrell Danielle
Radford what's going on you guys
nothing how you doing pretty good dan
you're gonna be holding down on the
facts so you have your fingers warmed up
to search some Shyamalan facts I'm so
ready to search anything M night
Shyamalan related and I'm even more
ready for the onslaught of people asking
why I liked glass because apparently the
critics didn't like it and I liked it oh
that's what I like about you Dan you
March to your own drummer
I see the critics like I'm a Takei yeah
but I am also a critic a lot of the
other critics didn't like glass and I
like yeah see I mean I mean I just
believe what the critics tell me you you
do you watch a movie and form your own
opinion that's two concepts yes right I
mean especially nowadays for real and
our friend Daniel Radford who's uh oh
just going to be chiming in and
delighting us all movie fights long but
also she's the voice of the people I am
the voice the people so for those of you
who don't know we do have a poll that
runs on the YouTube the poll options
will go up once all the fighters have
presented their initial arguments
because we want to keep this about
arguments if you want to find the poll
click up in the iCard if you're looking
for more just just for more details or
many questions click down the
description box below or you can find us
in the chat i will also be checking me
hashtag movie fights live a lot of
people you guys come in with some great
alternate answers some really really
funny memes all those things and so i
like to highlight so if you comment on
the movie fights live hashtag i might
pick yours isn't that delightful
danielle i thank you thank you sir
alright so again how this works there
are going to be three regular round
questions that we're going to go to the
speed round and who
ever emerges from that with four points
we'll walk out of here our champion will
it be a human will it be a felted friend
I do not know so and after the first
three rounds top two scores going to the
speed round and you could be down three
zip and make a furious comeback in the
speed round
it can happen ah y'all ready for this
jte drop that stick s package
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Thor alright so as as Dan
mentioned glass is opening this weekend
this is M Night Fights M fights Schama
on movie fights Shyamalan and fight
Shyamalan yes thank you Joe so question
number one we asked you so he's he's at
an up-and-down body of work some great
films some less than great films and
everything in between we asked today
question 1 what is the worst M night
Shyamalan movie and we start with player
number 1 cucumber well the only actual
answer to that question is the last
airbender he was given a perfect roadmap
of a masterpiece and normally I would
say you know you take a nap tations on
their own salt but literally it's so
well done you could take almost anything
from it and and and just duplicate it
and make it better but the only thing
that moves slower than the plot is the
bending in this film you have six guys
who make one stone move like five inches
all the kids are terrible actors which
is unfortunate especially a like oh
sorry
and yeah and the only person who has a
soul in the whole film is a guy playing
a IRL
everyone else is boring and wooden it's
it's quiet you don't care when anything
happens the power of water is like their
big moment and the whole thing and all
he does is lift a wave and do nothing
with it it's it's it's a complete wasted
effort it killed what could have been a
fantastic franchise and it was very
disappointing and hurt my soul a little
bit a soul hurting effort on be on the
part of Shyamalan according to cucumber
Sasha so I'm gonna go way back to his
film wide-awake which is such a boring
pile of oh sorry I already did
sorry but if you haven't seen it which
most people have not let me just tell
you this is what it says online a 10
year old Catholic school boy who
following the death of his beloved
grandfather embarks on a quest for the
meaning of life starring Rosie O'Donnell
what else do you need to know this is a
movie that M night Shyamalan said he
wanted to be a comedy that would make
people cry
Sowell comedies are supposed to do you
got Rosie O'Donnell in the Rosie
O'Donnell playing a nun which is just
uncomfortable you have a child who's
like of course the M night Shyamalan
part of it is that the end of this movie
spoilers if you don't want to know click
away five four three two one
his dead grandfather shows up at his
track meet in the end and that's how he
knows God exists what the why it's so
dumb
it is so sophomoric and the next year he
would make six cents this is everything
that we do not know I'm night Shyamalan
for and there's a reason for it because
he went completely off track it's
basically an overzealous Lifetime movie
and no one wants it I'm gonna charm
along lifetime movie Thank You Sasha Joe
what you got I will need a fact check
from Dan because I think Sasha made that
movie up my answer is the happening this
is this is when you look at the the M
night Shyamalan movie weird wouldn't
atmospheric there's a creepy twist
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
and I know I'm wearing a shirt that says
don't hate create right now so respect
to the man because the man takes swings
and he takes big swings sometimes they
work sometimes they head down and the
happening did not work he's mad at you
I've never in my life heard that sound
some kind of air switched on that we've
never heard before it's blowing really
hard yeah we may have a delightful
whooshing for the rest of the show which
is this is the happiest sequel we this
is the revenge absolutely you've lost
this angry wind quite possibly but I
know it's died down no guys I am seen
Joey did that just for effects didn't
I did okay time point Joe no I'm
kidding Joe continue please okay
wherever there are elements that that I
think make an M night movie and for some
of his movies and for some of his actors
you shake up that bag and it works and
it lands I'm breakable it works in at
land $0.06 works in it lands no matter
how clunky the dialogue no matter how
not human any of the human characters
seem to be but for the happening those
pieces absolutely don't fit together
there's no rhyme or reason you have you
have this weird wide-eyed performance
for Mark Wahlberg you have this weird
wide-eyed performance from Zooey
Deschanel you have these suicide scenes
that are meant to really invoke the
sense of dread but they just get
ridiculous like and no in no world
should a guy just sitting on the ground
and like cutting himself open with a
bottle make me laugh but somehow the
happening accomplishes that you have the
infamous third act thing with the cabin
and the old lady and what no
which is a which is a meme in itself and
then the twist that is you know the wind
got angry at us
it's the happening okay well the twist
the wind got angry at us what oh my god
speaking of Shyamalan twists this
question has a twist your answers will
remain the same but the question is now
what is the best we see with M night
Shyamalan movies do we see in wide awake
instead of us going to this weird wooden
performance we actually have a
delightful child that we all come to
love what he did with Haley Joel Osment
he also did with Joseph cross in
wide-awake you can have Robert loggia in
this movie Robert loggia is a national
treasure it's actually a comedy it's got
heart it feels good it's only about a
hundred minutes long thank God because
my trap my movies got long and instead
of him trying to be all like thinkI it's
just like do you love your grandparents
do you wish they were alive did they go
to heaven guess what they did kids and
I'll show up at your track me to cheer
you on
that's a feel-good movie you know the
strength of one of the big strengths of
M night Shyamalan exactly is that he he
doesn't just twist movies and plot but
he sub verbs he subverts expectations
the expectation that unbreakable in
class was supposed to be these big
superhero movies as we now modernly
define superhero movie see subverts that
and I think with the happening the big
thing that he subverts is the the idea
that the picture and what's happening on
screen is the only part of it movie
because the happening actually does
really work well go with me as an audio
drama as like an old-school weird
hitchcock ii am listening to and it's
all spooky on the radio War of the
Worlds radio drama the the the the
picture almost attracts but when you
just have the audio when you just have
that creepy atmosphere and score and it
leaves it up to your imagination when
all these weird suiciding things are
happening it's actually a really
effective scary spooky movie it's a
great movie if you don't watch it
let me tell you about why my last sermon
are so great you know they put a lot of
heart and soul into the production Zion
design of this film they've defined all
of the all the continents and they're
all the nations earth fire wind and
water very well to find visually you got
you got lots of representation of
different races and different different
types of folks within the within the
film including our heroes and our anti
heroes and that sort of thing you have a
complicated banished guy and uncle Iroh
who really all he is is loyal to his
nephew so you have some sweet
relationships buried in in this
otherwise fairly simple cucumber I feel
like you are describing the roadmap that
was handed to em Nigella mom but you're
not necessarily describing the drive
that he took using that map
he made the dragon I think there's just
something so inherently likable that
makes you really want to root for Mark
Wahlberg they call mr. glass you know
this is this is also a really cool
performance from Zooey Deschanel before
she was locked into new girl Manic Pixie
dream girl status this is when she was
still allowed to sort of like play
different characters and stuff like that
so there's something different with
Zooey John Leguizamo actually offers up
a really really great supporting role in
this movie he's someone who can take
Shyamalan dialogue and much like Bruce
Willis really knock it out of the park
and make it work so you're saying that
you like the idea of Mark Wahlberg as a
scientist absolutely found that
believable yeah no absolutely Mark
Wahlberg as a robotics inventor made
billions of dollars across the globe so
I think Mark Wahlberg has anytime kind
of science enthusiast nice you know I'm
there I'm going with this sure whether
in a cage Yeager or Mark Wahlberg in the
happening
I signed me up well for me I feel like
when you take such a sweet story about a
young boy it's something that we hadn't
seen from M night Shyamalan we didn't
really know what to expect for him yet
you talk about subverting expectations
he really subverted expectations because
he would go on from this to make the
sixth sense there were no expectations
to subvert yet at this point like it's
so impressive that he could do these two
things that he could do a beautiful
story about a child and his grandfather
and also do something about a child who
sees dead people that's amazing that's
that's breadth of available of knowledge
that's real I just think that the only
kind thing you can say about wide awake
is that it came out at a time where
there was no internet because that
really seems like it was his book of
Henry and we see what book of Henry did
to Colin Trevorrow it tanked his career
I think if we had been staring with
laser focus at up-and-coming directors
and stuff at the time we would not have
had a great movie like the happening
happen and that would have been tragic
and I feel like with The Last Airbender
we can all say that that's a film that
had so much potential that it just
didn't reach and I think that with this
movie he started his career in a really
small way so that he could grow and make
things like glass like split like Sixth
Sense but you have to first be able to
work with actors and get believable
performances and getting a believable
farangs out of a child is incredibly
difficult he did a great job with Joseph
cross but he did not allows Airbender to
that was all children but he started it
started with wide awake but I would like
to hear from cucumber just more things
he really loved about Airbender that's
here just some things you think about
late at night certainly oh man let's
just talk about opera and his adorable
Apple cheeks that are real real big in
this movie you gotta get some of playing
lemur-bat because they decided to add
back to it because you know people can't
figure out wings let's see they got some
wonderful beautiful well honestly
costume he was really good
we've heard we've heard a lot of good
stuff about what our potentially M night
Shyamalan best films let's shift gears
to final thoughts cucumber lay it on us
your final thoughts on why Last
Airbender is the best of M night last
airbender brought a new fantasy world to
to cinema it hadn't been seen before and
it's really hard for fantasy to do well
in theaters and I feel like it had an
expansive world that you could continue
to build upon is beautiful to look at it
had a lot to do with connecting to your
spiritual side and finding ways to other
than fighting which is an important
lesson I think in any any Goods heroic
story right yeah thank you cucumber
Sasha wide awake everything that you've
talked about starts in wide awake Utah
you have this sense of spirituality this
these beautiful connections among family
we don't have to worry about leg jumps
and starts and scares because what is
important in this movie is the heart and
we have a beautiful story well told
again Robert loggia and it deals with
epilepsy and there are not a lot of
movies that deal with epilepsy oh I feel
like that is important and something
that we should see more of and truly
Rosie O'Donnell should be given more
opportunities to play nuns okay Thank
You Sasha first time I've heard that Joe
first I want to note that cucumber has
sort of a smoky Demi Moore and Demi
Moore thing going high right now and
it's working it's working
this is this is the the conundrum I want
to present to you please Tommy was so
created the room to be a drama in the
spirit of Tennessee Williams he
obviously did not necessarily deliver on
that promise
and yet the room is a masterpiece of
bizarre choices very entertaining
performances did it hit the bull's eye
that it was aiming for no but hit this
bullseye over here and a bull's eye is a
bull's eye and I think the happening
falls within that same genre is it going
to be an all time compare with Hitchcock
thriller weird
what's going on here classic no is it
going to hit that other bull's eye where
we just really enjoy watching it with
our friends and pointing at it and going
what is happening yes it does and for
that reason the happening is a thank you
Joe star that is time right there Dan
Merle any facts ne-yo he asked for one
why the wake was indeed a film was
released on March 30th 1998 although it
was produced in 1995 and having
production budget of six million dollars
it was released in 43 theaters and
grossed a total of two hundred
eighty-two thousand one hundred and
seventy five dollars modest I collected
the I don't know why I collected the the
information from the critics on the
worst of M night Shyamalan that would be
the last airbender after earth and the
happening but now his best The Sixth
Sense signs and split are the ones that
his critics like the best so strangely
yeah it's really weird right strangely
one thing that I am an expert on for
some reason because I've seen it 20
times because I'm fascinated by it is
the happening so there are a couple of
small things that were incorrectly
stated about the happening number one
blue why would you mark Barger was not a
scientist he was a science teacher
teacher and John Leguizamo was not
cutting his glass his wrists with bottle
he was cutting it with glass from the
car accident he'd recently been in one
driver when there's a hole in the roof
of the Jeep and the Ramos group and the
driver went headfirst into a tree things
I'm here to do yeah a little bit of
crossover similarity between the
happening and bird box as far as the the
bird box at hat end happening share a
lot of DNA yeah a lot right and I would
be remiss if I did not ask you and I'd
be doing our fans a disservice I did not
ask you for a quick mark walberg still
it tastes least what No
okay so back to this round
Joe you made me laugh many times so
you're a little all over the place and
ye-jin wait an audio drama shut the
movie listen to it that's like that's
not serving the movie and then like the
bullseye thing that's like like if
you're going bowling and your ball
jumped into the next Lane you knocked
over all their pins so yeah good thing
man trouble know what that Billy I would
ever forget that
another way true and I said to me he
came down for it to Sasha and cucumber
here and I feel like yeah I mean I was
Sasha you pulled out some big guns at
the end there with the epaulets and
doing it but I I feel a cucumber best
imparted his simple vision of the world
created the set pieces the heart the
soul of the film
I feel like cucumber he he had a choice
it struck a chord in him and he stayed
on that path and his was the most
consistent argument so I'm gonna go with
cucumber and Merle yeah disagree with
you there a little bit how I felt that
this is somewhat easy for me I will
agree that Joe's justification it's
didn't quite strike home for me and I
felt like cucumber was reaching if I'm
being honest and I felt that Sasha was
the one who was able to effectively turn
turn the page and sell me on wide awake
the fact that it was a it's a child
performance it was what he had delivered
in later films that was a different kind
of movie and so Sasha actually has my
vote for for this argument all right
Sasha cucumber locked up at one one
let's go to Danielle with the people's
vote happening it's gonna be the
happening
57%
21% and wide-awake with 20% of them
knowing a thing that means it's up to
Danielle to voice her opinion to break
the tie people think all of these work
were fantastic arguments in this case I
gotta agree I'm going cucumber nice
cucumber takes the point Danielle other
answers for best or worse or any dank
grimy memes or anything
dirtier every week a lot of people
wondering why the village wasn't in
there a lot of people are wishing
wishing a cucumber
feel better because they're worried
about your sexy new voice yes your
number were you out like partying last
night or something yeah I'm a screamer
it's some smooth jazz but I was rocking
out anyways that sounds disruptive for
the other concert comfort twist on this
threw off everyone on Twitter so corner
pirate says these three are great at
lying yes
Thank You Danielle all right so it is
cucumber one Sasha and Joe looking to
get on the board here is question number
two so we've seen the worst case
scenario for EM Knight directing and
established property Avatar The Last
Airbender what IP would he be a just a
great fit to make the movie for just by
hand and glove perfect fit what IP is
this hand we're gonna twist you're not
gonna know until you have to know I will
say for the record there's no twist on
this question I'll start with Sasha
alright so I was thinking about things
that M night Shyamalan is good at and
that is like you said creating an
atmospheric performance he does a lot of
stuff with color theory in his movies he
gets amazing performances out of
children so I thought it would be very
very cool to see him take on Little Red
Riding Hood
we have seen him have Oh God not that
version that was horrible no that was so
bad no but I like the idea that actually
it's a great female performances like
Toni Collette in the sixth sense is so
underrated I love her so much she's
incredible and I would really like to
see what he did if he took on something
that would have elements of the village
that could have hints of lady in the
water but also brings in these this
child thing that he does so well that he
didn't wide awake that he did in the
sixth sense so we could see him take on
a young female in the woods and make it
really spooky and then do one of his
crazy amazing twists I think that would
actually be fascinating and if you took
the real fairy tale as opposed to you
that garbage movie that you just saw I
see free yes Amanda Seyfried it was like
right around the time of like Twilight
and the guy who was casting it didn't
make it into Twilight but he ended up in
this and now we didn't his name any
hooch because Catherine Hardwicke
directed that is not good Wow anyway but
I think that that would be very very
cool I would like to see that I think
he'd be great at Little Red Riding Hood
M night Shyamalan s Little Red Riding
Hood Joestar I'm gonna watch em nice
shall 'mon dieu little tag-team fun with
another horror guy Stephen King and I
would have M night Shyamalan direct The
Dark Tower
oh speaking of terrible movies that Lord
so here's something that the Dark Tower
got wrong the movie it was aside from
everything
it was literal everything was so literal
like there's an actual tower there's
like an actual controller of like every
like there was no magic or mystique
behind it and the Dark Tower series is
all mood it is all atmosphere it is
broken people dealing with a sort of a
suggested doom and scourge if you will
like it very rarely shows its face and
in fact the I think of some of the
points in which the books fall apart is
when the manifestation of the bad guy
shows its face but when it's just what's
going on this is spooky this is weird
it really works and that's also where M
night Shyamalan just absolutely shines
those are all those are all tools in his
toolkit broken protagonists sad and
somber people at the lowest point in
their life thrust into an extraordinary
situation Sascha mentioned color theory
Dark Tower is covered in color theory
and numerology and I think that that is
just the kind of stuff that M night
could just like take up bath in like a
big ol bucket of sand and he's a
chinchilla and he's just in there just
digging around in the chinchilla baths
and the Dark Tower yeah I just think
it's a real good fit Dark Tower
fYI chinchillas clean themselves by
rolling around and like sand and sawdust
right right yeah thanks Joe cucumber
what I've got alone with the island cuz
you know it was a fun idea was a good
concept but then Michael Bay decided to
blow the out of everything so I
don't know if I can say that but you
didn't you know that's like so imagine
it it's an escape from dystopia a story
without all of Michael Bay's BS you had
to focus on the characters the quiet
horror at the realization of what's
happening to them like within that
facility and in the escape we actually
get to zoom in and focus on the people
and less about the spectacle I'd also
love to see him try his hand at more
science fiction in general I think he's
got a good brain that could fit along
the lines of outer limits or Twilight
Zone that's kind of Abbas Ali and then
he could finally set something that's
not in the woods and not just rely on
that particular thing I think he should
stretch himself and try a little bit of
that I think he'd do well at the island
alright three different properties let's
fight it out you guys okay so M night
Shyamalan can barely execute one idea
you want him to take on the dark tower
yeah seems real real sketchy to me it is
and here's why it will work because take
a look at lady in the water which is
just concept after concept after concept
after concept after concept but then
look at Dark Tower it's the same thing
it's the same crazy mishmash Stephen
King even puts himself our alerts for
very old book series Stephen King
actually inserts himself into the story
as a character now that's the stuff
dreams are made of
bad bad bad bad what we want is exactly
what you're talking about like lurking
in the woods lurking danger is what mi
trommel on is great at and that's what
Little Red Riding Hood is like if you
take it where we don't know you talk
about a broken character at their very
bottom their grandmother has been eaten
alive they don't know they walk into
carnage there alone in the woods they're
trapped it's singular it could be so
creepy so atmospheric you take all the
stuff before we actually saw the thing
that they'd come for in signs which is
so dumb you can see all of that mystery
you can have all that terror and put a
child into it he's great about kids in
peril you put a kid in the woods alone
that's a movie that I think he could
absolutely execute it makes perfect
sense sci-fi is not his wheelhouse
sci-fi is not where my Shyamalan lives
and the Dark Tower I think would just he
would get so lost in it we would never
have something clear we need something
with Chas parameters he needs very very
clear concise like this is literally it
can be a three-page story there's a girl
she's in the woods grandma's dead here's
a big bad wolf yeah he can do the hour
flashback that you're going to get to
explain how the wolf could have possibly
done it because we as the viewer too
dumb to figure it out for ourselves as
opposed to how they got to the island
I think is missing some of the earmarks
that make an M night Shyamalan movie and
M night Shyamalan movie which is one of
the reasons I mean among many that
Airbender didn't work because airbender
that's not that's the best damn night
show that's okay that's fair sorry let
me retract that argument that Asylum I
think here's the thing yes lots of
concepts going around but the Dark Tower
is literally a paint-by-numbers for M
night Shyamalan it has everything that
he's into there is a kid lost in the
woods there is just weird doom there is
a section where they just have an
existential war of words with a devil
possessed train which is just nothing
but building suspension suspense and
tension and dread I mean this thing this
is literally training wheels for M night
Shyamalan to to work in another
properties right to pronounce his name
differently every single to have you say
yeah
he can handle that many ideas especially
there are parallel like planes of
existence in this world correct yeah oh
yeah yeah he can't handle that like lady
in the water you said it's all those
concepts but it's all around one house
and a pool and like the edge of a forest
and still it was just cluttered
cluttered story - sometimes a student
just needs a teacher and in this case
Stephen King is the obi-wan - that young
Luke and here's what here's what you do
here's how to do it right and you just
kind of have that Oh Eureka moment and I
think that's what the Dark Tower is
Chimel and what happened last time then
if they had the the paint-by-numbers if
they had the obi-wan then what happened
what you mean for Airbender no well that
- because airbenders not his color
palette hour was already terrible and
they already were shepherds yeah because
I do you can actually like sort of a
just a journeyman director that didn't
have any sense of tone or atmosphere
like em Knight does and so you lost all
the horror elements and all that what's
gonna happen next how elements from you
directed I need a fact check yes who
directed the other I don't remember
math on a cucumber I'd love to hear a
little bit more about your take on the
island certainly I guess I think it's a
it's a simple idea and I feel like the
the horror reveal of what they exist for
the clones figuring that out I think is
the sort of scene that he does
beautifully quiet darkly lit and that
realization that the panic of having to
get out that those kinds of quiet
moments are where he is strong not
necessarily anything that involves
gun-slinging of any kind or action or
violence he's no let people talk that's
what people talk or let people not talk
let people wander terrify in the woods
just run who's favored line for Best in
Show we can talk or not talk so he also
talked about how when is it wide awake
open doors for him to do other things I
think every time he stretches himself
that's when he does his best right the
next thing so the next thing was a sixth
sense so if he steps into sci-fi
maybe that could be as his other next
thing the next beautiful thing that he
could actually try to excel at which is
actually a great point and that's what I
would like to see him do with a female
protagonist because we've seen him sort
of rap movies around like women in peril
like split like six cents but he's never
had a woman be the center point of his
movie and I would love to see what he
does when he actually like because even
leading the water Bryce Dallas Howard is
not the center point of that movie like
everything's are times in the village
though right
oh that's what I'm completing a night
Shyamalan movies but it's still never
the center point like it's always the
woman is on the outskirts and I want to
see him take a young female protagonist
and just drive that car because I think
that that's something that really really
really would put propel his stereo
storytelling listen your final thoughts
please and please God let's not have a
cameo in my version there's very few
characters and though fewer characters
that he focuses on the better he does
six sense it's just two people like
really that's the center point of that
movie if he has a very very focused
vision if he has a template I think he
could make a beautiful driven dark
spooky freakout movie based on IP that
we're already super well aware of but
we'll give them night twists that we
will never see coming and I would
actually be fascinated to see where his
mind takes that story that we already
are so aware of Little Red Riding Hood's
actually the wolf what I don't know do
star with this biggest dark tower feels
it is still a small ensemble of
characters that just have horrible
things happening to them
you have Eddie the drug addict you have
Susanna I believe her name is I just got
that wrong I think she turns into
Suzanne anyway you have Roland your gun
slinger and you have Jake the boy in
peril and really in those books there's
again like that movie is a that movie
that came out too bad Tim because it's
not an action story there aren't a lot
of massive like jaw-dropping scenes of
gun slinging and stuff like that you
hear stories and flashback and tales of
the glory days when when roller was sort
of this King Arthur but really it's just
it's just playing in all these confusing
lore sandboxes and this is a case where
I think M night just throwing a bunch of
weird crap into a pile and seeing what
sticks works because that's what the
Dark Tower is that's almost the appeal
of the dark
where it's like journey by journey it's
like what's this random thing I don't
know what's this random thing I don't
know that's part of the appeal to it to
its fans the so I think that honestly
works for him and I just I just like I
want to see how he would push like the
numerology that Stephen King wrapped
everything around and I would even be
interested in you know you have again
you have Stephen King as a character
inside the books part of the storyline
of the books as Stephen King his
realities are collapsing basically
because he after his accident got really
in a dray you know he was screwing up
his own stuff he had to finish his own
story that's part of Roland's journey
how does then an equally egomaniacal
creator like M night also insert himself
into that I would honestly be fascinated
to see that like the adaptation on top
of the the meta of the novel whoa we
just got met on top of meta thank you
Joe
cucumber uh once again I think that M
night has a particular talent for making
us feel the dread of his characters and
I feel like dread is something that
hangs heavy in the story of the island
these people realizing know that they're
not even people anymore they're they're
their property they are harvested organs
their surrogate child givers they're not
it's a terrible way to claw your way out
of when you don't know what the actual
world is and you realize that the escape
is all you have you don't know what
you're gonna be on the other side and I
think that those kinds of thoughts are
the things that he does very very well
and I'd love to see him do it I still
think that he should stretch into sci-fi
it might not be his wheelhouse but I
think we all like it better when he
tries something new
thank you cucumber and that is time Dan
Morell please talk to us about facts and
then go ahead and tell us your thoughts
on this question sure the dark tower
circuit by nicolai or Nick Kailash
ourself
oh yeah Nicolai yeah Red Riding Hood
came out in 2011 it was directed by
Catherine Hardwicke and written by David
Leslie Johnson McGoldrick who go on to
write many things including The Walking
Dead and Aquaman and wrote many things
before that and you're right Sasha Toni
Collette was great in the sixth sense as
a matter of fact Toni Collette was
nominated for an Oscar for the sixth
sense much like she should be nominated
hashtag and Oscar for Tony with an I
respect the spelling yeah it all comes
around yes it does yes it does um as far
as my thoughts go I gotta say I mean I
thought the Jo joke sort of uh he took a
big body blow
and then he doubled down on it right
again at the end which was the whole the
last thing we want is to see him die put
himself into his own movie that this
disastrous that's part of what's been
the problem going forward I agree with
Sasha's point bringing that up and the
doubling down I don't think plus it just
sounded like a mess to me is like
throwing stuff at the wall and it's the
Dark Tower and the kid but inside of it
is a meta-narrative on top of that
that's what the books are yes but it
just it did not sound like the best fit
or the best film for me fair so but it
was between cucumber and Sasha and again
I I liked I liked Sasha's strategy there
I liked the fact that she was going for
something that was very simple that was
very atmospheric that didn't leave a lot
of room for over complication that was
just a very straightforward story with
Red Riding Hood and so that's what I'm
gonna go for my vote goes to Sasha thank
you Dan
yeah Joey you painted something it's
kind of fascinating like if M Knight
could take a little bit of the piss out
of himself and in that way and and
journey into his film then maybe but
yeah it just seemed overly complicated
and I find lady in the water repellent
and it's just there's so many just like
dangling threads and weird just details
that like are that I just did not get on
board with him that movie so it started
to feel like we were getting into that
territory so yeah it came down to a
sashan cucumber to me and hmm yeah I
feel like we just had a little bit more
of a clear vision of what Sasha's would
be even though cucumber made a decent
argument for the island yeah I'm also
going with Sasha so Sasha you take the
point
talk to us all right okay with 41
percent of the vote the Dark Tower Oh 32
percent went to Little Red Riding Hood
and 26 percent for the island a lot of
people first off do put a an Oscar for
Tony it's happen an Oscar hashtag an
Oscar for Tony nice I know the voting
nomination voting is closed I think we
can still will this into existence
these things can't happen we don't
secret it you guys yes it must happen it
must happen and then I'm so forensic
underscore chick on Twitter says can I
nominate M night to do a Muppet movie I
would watch the hell out of that and as
a reminder you did do this to our little
movie that's true I was not liking that
suggestion stay away from my people
[Laughter]
cool Thank You Danielle so moving into
question number three is Sasha one
cucumber one Joestar looking to get on
the board this is it all right well here
it is
now that unbreakable finally has a
follow-up
what other M night movie most deserves a
sequel and go ahead and pitch it so
question three start with player three
mr. Joestar I went with the sixth sense
from a purely like dry businessí angle
this is the only other M night movie
that I think anyone would be like
interesting I think the moment he goes
he's like time for signs to
or lady in the water episode 1 and I
think everyone just sort of walks out on
him but Six Senses is the one where
people I think would kind of go yeah ok
so here's my pitch for for the sixth
sense Cole are our young man who
famously saw dead people has grown up
now in the public eye he you know just
like you know the the Miss Cleo's and
stuff of the past that could talk to
your relatives and read your fortune and
stuff like that Cole grew up in the
public eye is this guy who could as this
medium who could who could talk to your
dead relatives and help them resolve
issues and move on and stuff like that
and he's sort of this big child star you
know he has his own ghost hunter show
and you know all that all that crap and
then eventually as the public always
does with younger stars they turn on him
he sort of forgot and he becomes a joke
so now you have this young man you know
who's mid-30s something like that who is
has spent his life sort of trying to
find to give meaning to the dead who now
sort of has to find some meaning in his
own life so that is six cents to six
cents to we're on the horn to cucumber
guy I'm going with the village too so as
you remember from the village it was the
coming edward Walker's fortune in
Covington that was keeping the entire
village protected right it was paying
for the rangers to stay there and keep
people out so this one story takes place
with the next generation in Covington
the fortune has run out there's a
government shutdown so there are no more
Park Rangers reforms ahead wise so
there's a financially and emotionally
struggling family as he's now abounding
wildlife preserve is a wonderful place
to have a free vacation the father makes
everyone wear matching t-shirts for the
trip of course they're all red the bad
color they stumble upon the village
thinking that there are free available
cabins because they have approached a
wearing red people who live there are
now hiding in the woods and it will be a
fight to get their home back to get the
village back so it's going to be a clash
of worlds and beliefs and
knowledge of what is out there and
whither then violently will it in
peaceably whose minds will be blown
worlds collide in the village to Sasha
what do you got well I'm really glad
Daniel brought up Stuart little because
we're bringing it back this is a
different kind of sequel though rather
than just doing a sequel because there's
already been three Stuart littles a
little jokey we are going to allow this
to be a full Stuart little reboot so the
first one was written by M night
Shyamalan he did not direct it also they
took the heebie white book and they kind
of threw it up a window like it did not
at all adhere to the eb white book in
this one we were actually going to pay
respect to the book now if you have not
read the book it's super weird there's a
normal family grown in New York who have
a child and the child is born a little
rat and they treat the rat as it is it
is their child and they raised it and
they're worried about how it will be in
the world will people accept it will
people fear it will people hate it and
by the time the rat is 6 years old or 7
years old it already speaks thinks and
behaves like a teenager so it's a genius
rat 2 so what I want to see is let's
have M night Shyamalan not just right
but also direct this movie once again
bringing a child in peril and let's not
do the Jonathan Nikki Geena Davis
version let's do the dark creepy what
the hell is happening Stuart little
version that actually because most
children's stories are super weird and
upsetting and we glossed over that with
the first one here's an opportunity to
take that what would happen if there was
a rat in New York that was trying to
live peaceably live its life and people
were always out to kill it he's being
hunted by the cat there's a half-dead
bird that they find on the windowsill
that's his one true friend and the cat's
always trying to kill the bird it's dark
it's filled with terror and I think it
would be awesome give me a new Stuart
little dark creepy Stuart little alright
let's fight it out I like an M night
story that just has a big weird esoteric
philosophical question and I think if if
solving the problems of dead people
doesn't give my life any joy then what's
the point in doing it is like a big fun
weird philosophical question for M night
to sort of explore
or and wrap his head around and I think
the sort of paranormal in pop culture
has now evolved so much you know again
you have these affer mentioned weird
ghost hunter shows you have Ghost
Adventures which is just literally all
these like game cookie kind of like
ghost Bros that just go into houses and
they're like hey you killed somebody
with an axe 2x and B bro thrown X at me
and so you know not to sound like my
father how but like people just don't
respect the world of the paranormal
anymore
and is the world that this this this kid
that had an actual link to it has grown
up in and I just think that's a really
cool interesting world to explore this
guy actually trying to use his talents
to in communicating and communing with
the dead to sort of pull his life back
together okay honestly if you had said
Toni Collette is dead something happened
with Donnie Wahlberg and now he's trying
to reconnect with his mother and there
was like some dark thing that happened
with his mother that's a movie I would
actually really like to watch but you
just invoked Dane Cook and said at the
top this is just a very business the
idea o- li6 since it's already a really
good movie we don't need another version
of that and the village I feel like what
you pitched cucumber is more of an
action movie than it is an actual M
night Shyamalan movie oh that's not at
all what I was picturing well it sounded
for thee for the people the visiting
family it's it's a it's a cabin in the
woods horror film there's these creepy
people and pilgrim type tire trying to
break in and scare them away from the
home for the people who are living in
the village it's they're being attacked
by these monsters they've been told
about their entire lives so it's them
literally facing their demons while the
other people think they're the enemy
well what is what if you've always been
seen as the enemy what if you are a rat
that has always been hated what if you
have always been reviled and you finally
go out into the world where there are
monsters that are a hundred feet tall
because that's how big humans must look
to rats and they all want to kill you
what about that that's actually an
incredibly dark beautiful movie that
could tell a story and not like in your
home the one place that you should feel
safe something stalks you night and day
this
creepies white cat that is a truly great
movie that could bring chills could
bring thrills and could ask big
questions and t's just life lessons and
it's right for a cameo by Samuel Jackson
just an issue I have you know you sort
of mentioned creepy children's stories
and movies and I think everyone at this
table grew up on some really really
bizarre children's stuff and it ruined
all of us and I don't like none of us
are okay and I don't want to I you know
a lot of our friends have you I don't I
don't want your daughter to watch this
weird movie scene Eyes Wide Shut in the
shining like my goodness wasn't me it
was her dad anyway she's fine so far so
far your sixth sense to Joe sounds a lot
more like a workplace comedy the way
you're framing it cuz it's like at this
point the ghosts are no longer scary
like he's got that down pat so it's just
gonna be all the press at work every day
yours is also it reminded me of another
film Tucker and Dale vs. evil which is a
very underrated comedy no you should go
see regardless of the outcome of this
round test I will just be talking about
Tucker Dale vs. evil from here on out
which is another sort of you know sort
of mistaken identity we're all sort of
going at each other and a man falls into
a wood chipper and Alan Tudyk occurs I
mean yeah you can I guess you could
point at this and sort of frame it as a
workplace con but you could also sort of
look at the original and just frame it
as child walks around with sad man for
an hour and a half you know you could
always sort of like poke and prod at
this stuff molested in the idea of
whether it's cold from the sixth sense
or whether it's the three ninjas from
three ninjas what happens to all these
kids after they've gone through these
weird traumatic things as adults and I
think em night could have a really
interesting take on you know what
happened to this bizarre kid that from a
very young
has been dealings your final thoughts
with dead ghosts and cleaning up other
people's problems I just think there's a
lot of meat there there's an interesting
sort of very sort of evenly pace just
like all of his stuff is sort of problem
to explore over the course of a feature
thank you Joe
cucumber final so toni collette is dead
and something weird happened to her man
you threw in a little twist at the end
there
cucumber all right it's it's got the
best of signs it's got the best of the
village where it's it's people who are
trying to defend their homes against
invaders and and in this case neither
party means either any actual ill
they're just both terrified so it comes
down to when they meet what do they do
how are they going to respond to this
and how is that family going to explain
to these crazy pilgrim people like hey
this isn't the world let's show you the
world and that leads to a whole new way
of opening up their lives because they
they ended trapped at the end of the
village so that this is their way out
but will they accept it or will they not
will they fight against that thought and
just get these people off their land
kill them or what have you there's traps
already built into village I think it
would be very very interesting to have
that that kind of spooky everyone's
scared no one knows what's going on but
when you find out it's even worse you
raised a lot of interesting questions
Thank You cucumber Sasha so I think that
M night Shyamalan does his best work
where he's in a world that is
recognizable to us like in the sixth
sense like in unbreakable or split where
you can recognize this world and you
know that you live in it also
but then something terrifying happens
like signs you know I'm not that scared
about aliens I feel like we could bro
down with Stuart little I think that you
could create something that is so
fascinating where I hate rats I am
terrified of them I think a lot of
people would look at that and be like I
can't be with that same way the creepy
kids okay the kids scared the living
hell out of me so take that but you take
that you twist it in the M night
Shyamalan Oman Oman Auma and then you
make it something that is not only
recognizable but also preys on our
biggest fears and is illuminating and at
the end of the day gives us a story that
we can really root for and get behind
and with twists that we never saw coming
I think that Stewart little which we
already know he knows well and probably
didn't get to do the version that he
wanted to the first time around but it
did make 300 million dollars he could do
that real justice now time all right
there you have it
dan Morelle where are we on the facts
you know I know a lot of people would
probably say this Ashley Stewart littles
not a rat he's a mouse he is actually
originally written to be a mouse a rat
he was a mouse very cute mouse in the
movie version Macaulay woods so that is
not a factual error on Sasha's part that
factually that's all that I really have
very good sir thank you for saving my
ass yes of course yeah three three three
cool pitches here I hmm yeah Sasha I
really found yours interesting like
around me like some kind of like Edward
Gorey kind of just like like
turn-of-the-century kind of creepy story
Joe I thought I really liked yours too I
mean it was not just a sixth sense
sequel but it kind of ascends up on like
some of the realities on Rah's that we
see today and like like what happens to
a child star dealing with that cucumber
I'm just surprised that you had all
those facts on lock from the village oh
my god I forgot so much of that so thank
you for reminding me of that at the end
of the day came down to Sasha and Joe
for me yeah and I don't know I just I
was just a little bit more excited about
some of the elements in Joe's pitch
seeing what this guy that was so
tormented grew up to be and also to send
up on these bro out Ghost Hunters type
shows that's what I would like to see
Moe some go and Joe Dan a different way
only because I was I was kind of split
and so it comes down to
my thoughts are unbreakable cumber push
Joe on the genre of his thing a little
bit and I feel like Joe didn't really
fight back it's like well ok yeah you
could say it's that and then he just
came one for very specific two very
broad and I was like well you know well
I'm really more interested in just like
kids growing up and I felt like it lost
some of its focus like I think that's
where you really got a bore down on
these ideas and I felt like Joe allowed
himself to be pushed a little wider it
was actually between Sasha and cucumber
for me okay and I actually feel like and
I got one bite at the Apple with Stuart
little already and and to reboot for me
I don't know that that wasn't as
appealing as I liked the idea of
advancing where the village went the
fact that it is this kind of survival
you're bringing in new blood but at the
same time you're bringing in these older
characters to clash with them that's the
pitch that excited me the most about
what that movie would be so I'm gonna go
with cucumber okay one for Joe one for
cucumber Danielle can you uh put an end
to these shenanigans of round three um
maybe yeah yeah let's see alright with
48% of the vote we have six seven yeah
yeah with 36 percent vote at the village
- 15 percent of the vote for Stuart a
little too so there we go
is like there is one dude that keeps
being like it's reboot it to reboot it's
not a sequel I see you dude I promise
it's I like to wait until I to bring out
points like that and not call someone
out in the middle of their argument
because that's not nice yeah I like to
let them have their argument before we
make those small points secondly mark I
don't have a last name in the chat and
you didn't say this on Twitter and I
wish you had he pitched village to the
city could be a fish out of water story
a comedy of these goofy Villa villagers
almost getting hit by cars oh my god yes
like run the Springer for the village
yes
Quaid and kingpin only if they do the
thing without any punctuation so it's
like the word to but it's like also like
like taking the place of the word to the
cities it's like village to the city
[Music]
that makes it a light-hearted goof
around it does I'm not directing
unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt yeah
unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt here's a twist
we're all tied up 3 3 first of all okay
let's go to the tiebreak so the tiebreak
works thusly I'm going to ask you the
question call out your answers then it
works kind of like the speed round where
we'll hear in the order that you
answered lleol each get 20 seconds to
elaborate and then we'll go back in the
same order and you'll get 10 second
rebuttals y'all ready for this let's do
it is it also about in my jaw line
you're about to find out what 2018 film
would have been most improved if you
replace the director with M night
Shyamalan place quiet place Sasha
waiting on cucumber and Joe Roma the
predator the predator Avengers in video
lose the Russo brothers swapping Chum on
ok so we have the quiet place from Sasha
the predator from Joe and Avengers
infinity Wars from cucumber
Sasha 20 seconds begin as soon as you
speak a quiet place is everything we
know and love about Emelec shyamalan
place in the woods children in peril
people like unseen monsters but it was
directed by the guy who previously had
only done the haulers and just didn't
bring a real horror sensibility I
literally laughed multiple times out
loud watching that movie I kept thinking
if somebody farts they die why didn't
they just live behind the waterfall
there were too many quest
left unanswered and I feel like M night
Shyamalan could have really taken that
Joe I think radzinsky really nailed that
movie and if you're worried about M
night being able to make a horror movie
make you laugh less his track record
says no you're going to crack up at his
version of a quiet place whereas the
predator very simple guy in forest guy
being hunted by an unseen force that's
all the predator is and I can pull that
off that's all it needs to be the
predator was just this big complicated
dumb box-office thing but just needs to
be some vegetable so it's all one family
it's basically signs but in the Avengers
University of an entire family watching
all the events happen around as I like
all the fantasies little monster guys
are breaking in through the door so it's
these people trying to survive because
the old heroes are gonna be fine so it's
them it's it's the regular guy trying to
survive in this horrible horrible
superhero world
Krasinski needed help the predator is
already perfect we never even needed
that movie and infinity war that is just
not a version that anybody wants to see
and of course we know the heroes are
gonna be ok but we want them to actually
be imperiled and nobody wants to see the
Avengers actually imperiled Joe I
actually agree with the lack of stakes
for the heroes but you lose that epic
punchy punch that's why I go to the
Avengers that's why I go see that movie
again the the predator became this
overcomplicated thing that I think Emma
I could really nail again predator is
nothing if not a badass and Shyamalan
does not do badass well at all like I
can't picture him having some awesome
like muscle guy going around slicing
people up and ripping out spines under
someone's hand it would be way too quiet
can I just get a high-five from Q come
around now because that was so legit all
right so it's time for us to choose who
does not move on and Danielle you have
your own thoughts and opinions on this
one now right so why don't we go ahead
and start with Danielle
Radford who does not move on oh these
were all such great and inventive
answers I'm so happy with each and every
one of them for who I would choose not
to
move on based off of only this round I
I'm gonna have to go with Sasha on this
one as much as I loved that I didn't
just and the firts and the waterfall is
in Sean wanna answering that I don't
know if you proved enough that he would
actually be able to answer those
questions because sometimes he can't do
that his own movies
alright so it's one for Sasha I'm
actually gonna go with cucumber on this
sorry buddy but yeah I mean you you
pitched a version of Avengers that
really didn't have a lot of the Avengers
in it and like doesn't have a badass
like or he can't do a badass Thanos is
kind of a badass so yeah I just didn't
get your version of it so I'm going
cucumber Dan Merle for me when you're
talking about what improving I think I
think a part of your argument has to be
what does this person bring to the table
and I I know that cucumbers vision was
certainly way different than the
Avengers but I thought that he brought a
very interesting view of what Shyamalan
would have done with it and I also think
Joe did the same with the predator and I
felt with Sasha it was more of just hear
the things that I didn't like about the
quiet quiet place but I didn't feel as
much about like what Shyamalan would do
for it so I'm gonna agree with Danielle
and I would actually advance cucumber
and Joe there you have it
you fart you're dead I gotta agree with
your clam place yet why don't you not
move behind the waterfall it pissed me
off that should have been the tagline if
you fart you're okay let's move on to
the speed round the tiebreaker does not
count for a point so Josette 1 cucumbers
at 1 and we are going into the speed
round and it works the same as the
tiebreak we just did I'll ask the
question first first first person to
answer gets to elaborate on their answer
first 20 seconds 20 seconds 10 second
rebuttal 10 second rebuttal locked up at
1 1 here is the first question of the
speed round best ever performance in any
M night film what is it Bruce Willis
unbreakable
Sam Jackson and unbreakable okay whoa
all right we have Bruce Willis vs. Sam
Jackson same movie unbreakable Joe you
spoke first 20 seconds begin when you
speak now Bruce Willis in unbreakable
gives us this beautiful range of emotion
of from this man trying to find his
place in the world and he doesn't do in
these epic oh this is so cool chronic
walls superhero ways the ways what he
the reality of what's happening to him
hit him are just beautiful and sad the
moment where he nods to his son that
he's right that he could do these things
is so beautifully understated and
gorgeously played it's so subtle there
is a frailty to Sam Jackson that is not
seen anywhere else and anything he's
ever done he's always the Banff but he's
never this broken man searching for hope
and he does it so beautifully in this
film and it's the most memorable thing
about that movie to me not even I'm even
think about well so anything in that
movie I think about Sam Jackson being so
sad
I think for Sam Jackson as a foil
performance to work you need that root
in that anchor of Bruce Willis and what
that character also involves depending
on when you see that movie as a kid if
he just wants to see a superhero finally
step up and punch Bruce Willis could
have been replaced by a boulder with
legs I think it wasn't a particular
performance of death in that movie he's
Bruce was being Bruce Lewis as he's
always being Prost freakin Willis
Sam Jackson actually showed range in
depth okay yeah I got a go cucumber on
this one
he just cucumber your description of Sam
Jackson's performance made me feel
something
Daniel Radford I've got to agree I've
got to go keep coming from this one I
think it's that last that last salvo
against Bruce Willis his performance is
what did it for me yeah bolder with legs
okay it what's that poor Bruce Willy Oh
Pro poor Bruce Willy is uh the legend of
Bruno okay it is - one cucumber going to
question number two of the speed round
here it is what movies better
unbreakable or split unbreakable okay we
heard Joestar first with unbreakable
Joestar twenty seconds begin whenever
you speak cucumber s split split goes
into bad directions it turns into girl
on a cell torture porn which is not done
well in the movie and we've seen it
enough it's done to death James McAvoy
his performance is incredibly overrated
it's just a guy doing different accents
I can do that for the rest of the speed
round if you'd like me to in fact I will
my neck speed round question I'll be a
British person it's just a point where
it's unbreakable is this beautiful
melancholic ode to the superhero well I
would agree that in all not all like
twenty whatever personalities within him
were completely defined them the major
ones were and they're very clear both
and body posture facial expression and
vocal dexterity that is the mark of a
very strong actor with great range not
just it isn't just voices it is it is it
is posturing it is intent it is acting
and it was a full strong performance
ten-second rebuttals sorry writers
voices and different sweaters where is
unbreakable the tone the score the
atmosphere the twist that you didn't see
coming no one even knew this was a
superhero movie it still stands up today
it's a fantastic film no no is a
superhero movie the guy ran a comic shop
let's calm down for just a minute there
everyone know where they were in
therefore they know what they were
getting there were no surprises but yeah
it felt okay but let's split as did
something uh fantastic and Merle hmm
I have movie fought Joe starred Spencer
go right on this James McAvoy thing for
like two years now and I will continue
to do so however based on the arguments
I feel like cucumber was just a little
too much put on his heels and on the
defensive and I feel like Joe is able to
make more points for his movie so I
would have to go with Joe yeah Dan your
thoughts on McEvoy's performance aside
which I actually I side more with you
than our friends Joe and Spencer I agree
with everything else you said about Joe
putting cucumber on his heels here and
taking the point I really like Joe's
comment about it being an ode to the
superhero movie um great so this is
question number three of the speed round
here we go who has them who has had the
overall better career em Knight or
Michael Bay Emily okay Joe gets Bay and
Joe is Bay cucumber twenty seconds begin
for your defense of M night whenever you
begin speaking say what you will about
his successes or failures he can only
fail as hard as he does because he
actually tries something different every
time he tries to make a film he takes
risks he tells his own stories he's
mostly self-produced now because he
wants to tell the stories that he wants
to tell and that can't be said for
Michael Bay who's just a giant
commercial explosion machine there's no
thought or heart behind what he does
yeah I think the difference between
these guys is that M night was
immediately handed all the money and
then they took the money away
immediately because of what he was
capable of Michael Bay earned the money
made money with that money and is able
to on his own terms pull back and do
smaller things like pain and gain which
is this fantastic really fun character
piece before going back to blow him up
switch part of your career is making
money and the dude makes money while on
top of that you know bad boys fantastic
movie one of the best buddy cop movies
of the nineties hey hey create don't
hate buddy
yeah someone made some beautiful
beautiful things and things that would
not exist without his brain granted he's
very he loves himself as well but he
makes he makes very very alright I think
the difference is in the lows and M
nights lows make you go stop making
movies and Michael Bay's lows make GUI
let's go that was a cool explosion and I
like that American flag like the
aesthetic is still there like you can
still sit and watch without being
completely angry what time is it always
in a Michael Bay movie what time is it
all the time is it always in a Michael
Bay movie close in time no you said it's
always like the perfect setting so it's
always on a flag farm near the sunset I
agree both fantastic arguments but Wow i
Q comers opening was so strong and I
think he laid a great bedrock and Joe
was poking holes in it but I think
overall strength of argument I think you
come and make such a compelling case I'm
gonna go cucumber real real close for me
but I feel like Joe eked it out in the
end so it is Joe three cucumber two
going to question four this is game
point cucumber you need this to keep her
going Joe you take this you take the day
all right boy
Steven Spielberg film would you most
want to see M night remake ai ai and
don't say what nothing The BFG The BFG
all right we have AI verse the BFG
cucumber time begins as soon as you
start speaking
well Shyamalan already has some great
work with children actors and he said
he's worked with Haley Joel Osment as
well and I think that he would bring to
it though it had a dark tone to begin
with he would make it a little bit
darker and we wouldn't have that blue
fairy post scene where everything's all
happy happy-go-lucky goodbye waving huh
daddy hey that scene leaving time on the
table Joe I think the question is like
which one of these needs to be rebooted
I agree that last scene at the very end
of AI is it ruins an otherwise very
wonderful movie but if you're just doing
this to clip a scene then who cares B if
G is a is a Spielberg miss it deserves
some redemption it's a it's a it's a
classic children's story that I think M
night Shyamalan could have a lot of fun
with again little kid in peril rebuttals
yeah I think under Shyamalan I could
focus so much more on the on the robots
experience less on the world at large
and more about the robots as as
themselves as people and focusing mostly
on the kid and the experience and all of
that one
ái needs the the heart and empathy that
Spielberg delivers to work whereas The
BFG just needs an intellectual sort of
connection between Kidd and giant and
sort of exploring the ideas within it
but and I can't bring that heart time
all right whoo damn rural I felt like
cucumber with a I brought up a
difference in tone as well as the
difference in worldview in perspective
that a knight would bring whereas I felt
Jose Rutledge solely more I just like it
wasn't a very good Spielberg film he
brought the kids stuff in at the end but
I heard more about what M Knight would
bring to it from cucumber so I'm going
with cucumber I gotta agree with you
again Dan we are all tied up at 3 3 the
game a great moment in sports indeed if
you remade the Sixth Sense today who
should play the Bruce Willis role dr.
Malcolm Crowe Tony Shalhoub Tony
Shalhoub Steven root Wow we heard
Shalhoub first time begins as soon as
you speak Joe from Galaxy Quest tomb is
amazing we've seen Tony supers as a
performer who can do it all and as this
this guy sort of lost and sad who's just
lost his marriage and has this weird
connection with this kid I think Tony
Shalhoub would knock that out of the
park the performance is all in the eyes
and Tony Shalhoub has like the saddest
eyes in the business right now he would
just nail that plus he would pull off
that tweed suit really really well I
think he could add little spots of humor
whether necessary I want to talk about
versatility Steven Hurd is one of the
most varied character actors in
existence today and he's been working
non-stop since forever but he would also
bring such heart he immediately
connected that man any time he's on a
screen you feel for his soul and imagine
that wedding scene with the ring being
slid across the table Steven root on the
other side looking all sad victories
character from True Blood the saddest
vampire in the world
I think part of what works with the
twist of six cents is that when you
realize that he is dead you also realize
that you don't actually want him to
leave because you you've appreciated his
journey you appreciate his connections
in the progress that he's made and I
think Tony should we could really near
the performance the best thing about
Shalhoub performances are his aloofness
and I think that that disconnect is what
make some humorous and funny and fun to
watch but I feel like Stephen root is
always grounded no matter how ridiculous
he's being and in this case you wouldn't
even be ridiculous you'd be this
beautifully grounded alright Daniel
Radford oh my goodness I do I want to
see both of those movies I think right
at the end cucumber got me by mentioning
Tony Shalhoub Zaloom as' and the
immediate connections that you would get
with a Stephen root so I'm going with
you cover I have to agree with Danielle
cucumbers just he's locked it in at the
end to come or time Joe star amazing
work it was entertaining fun um Sasha oh
great stuff
cucumber tell us where we can find you
well you can find me at cucumber lives
on Twitter and also at twitch.tv slash
perceptions studio well played
cucumber you know what some people were
wondering if you were a flash in the pan
after winning after one question on our
women in film special but you're proven
that you've you come to play you're here
to stay cucumber nicely done Joe star
great suck you you push this felted
friend to the limit man I gotta tell
Tony I'd let him down
later boobs gonna hate me for this you
know I would take a say I want to echo
that because we brought in a cucumber
because he's a great improviser a really
funny performer and it is always a
pleasure watching someone get better and
better
and better at this floor mat it's a
really cool thing to be able to watch
and so just getting to the show with you
and my girlfriend
mr. programmer I always love it when
you're here as well and without this is
a super fun super good time oh thanks
brother good times Sasha you always just
like you you enlighten us and you
delight us every time you're here I'm so
delighted to have been here with
cucumber I mean this was an honor I mean
just start like this is this is this is
kind of tell us where we can find you
you find me on Twitter and Instagram at
Sasha pearl raver and probably at home
watching the shining with my 10 month
old thank you for kid wait for the
politically out of the elevator please
tell us one more time how we can support
Toni Collette and her bid for Oscar gold
at this point now a hope and a prayer at
best
however if anyone has any heist planning
that we could perhaps pull off a heist
to make this down we like to and
la-la-land debacle it's not an
uncrackable system house right I'm
saying I would never encourage criminal
activity but you know you just did agent
fielder figured this out the Emmys right
did he for Nathan for you yeah you did
like a whole video where it's like
here's how you pack me well I'm just
saying that that that we're in the
endgame yeah and this to happen
the mom is coming to Collette there must
be some justice in these Oscars for Toni
Collette because hereditary will never
ever happened again hopefully right on
Oscar for terrible realization Oscar you
know
Torretta Terry know how to read read
read read it to reader
Daniel Radford thank you for being a
delightful and a ray of sunshine and a
voice of the people please go ahead and
shout out some stuff yeah find me on
social media twitter at daniel Radford
on Instagram Daniel underscore Bradford
and I have a patreon where we watch some
wrestling mostly bad movies these days
and we talk about him in our discord and
it's really really fun so coming up that
sounds like good times yeah I guess
thank you guys for watching this was
super fun Congrats again cucumber Thank
You jte thank you for Billy biz for
holding it down making this show happen
and thanks to Al Nation hashtag the
hooligans hashtag Percival power hashtag
hoot-hoot uh we'll see you next time
fights bye-bye
[Music]
you